Kiev's Independence Square is a living
monument to revolution a bastion of
people power or Ukrainians United to
overthrow a corrupt and unpopular
president our last president yanukovych
he's he is very bad man and all
Ukrainians want to kill him last winter
hundreds of thousands of Ukrainians
gathered here engaging in pitched
battles with their former presidents
government it was the second time in a
decade protesters have occupied the
square Yanukovych is gone now and
Ukraine's new rulers brought to power by
the squares very revolutionary say they
must go they've served their purpose
they may even be a threat suddenly
there's division on this squares purpose
well with the election of a new
president probably it should slowly go
away and see the policies of a new
president and how is it go it was
independent square has done its job but
the government hasn't and we won't leave
until they deliver on their promises for
now the main battleground for Ukraine's
new president is in the east but the
Capitals main square has already become
a challenge in its own right after Petro
poroshenko was elected the police came
to move the protesters but were sent
away